hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show today show is sponsored by
expressvpn don't let big tech track what
you do anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com well today is of course
memorial day i thought we'd talk a
little bit about what memorial day means
obviously
everybody is out having a day off and
many folks
are in fact paying attention to the
nature of memorial day and the solemnity
of the day and what it sanctifies and of
course what it does sanctify is
americans who have fallen on the fields
in order to make sure that america
remains free which does
require us to understand why america is
free what our freedoms
are and and why those freedoms matter
and in a time when when those ideologies
are
under desperate attack both domestically
and abroad it's important to
recapitulate that the declaration of
independence
stands for eternal and true human values
that america's freedoms that have made
the world a better
freer and more prosperous place have
been spread abroad and protected at home
by the people
who died in order to do that memorial
day began
originally it was it was first observed
right after the civil war
according to history.com by the late
1860s americans in various towns and
cities had begun holding springtime
tributes
to countless fallen soldiers decorating
their graves with flowers and reciting
prayers
it's not clear exactly when this began
but in 1966
the federal government declared that
waterloo new york was the official
birthplace
of memorial day waterloo celebrated the
day on may 5 1866 it was chosen because
it hosted an annual community-wide event
during which businesses closed
and residents decorated the graves of
soldiers with flowers
and flags this became decoration day on
the first decoration day
general james garfield made a speech at
arlington national cemetery 5 000
participants decorated the graves of the
20 000 civil war soldiers who were
buried there
and this became very common across the
united states
for decades memorial day was observed on
may 30th because that was the
day back in 1868 that had originally
been served
but in 1968 congress then passed the
uniform monday holiday act
that said that memorial day would be the
last monday in may
so i i thought that today would be an
excellent time
to just talk about some of the people
who have sacrificed their lives
for america and a huge number of us know
people who have served in the military
have grandparents who served in the
military maybe parents maybe you served
in the military but the stories of
heroism medal of honor recipients
they truly are astonishing when you
realize that these are the heights that
human beings can attain in defense
of home and hearth and defense of
american freedom
it's awe-inspiring and and it should
make all of us
a little bit more humble about the fact
that we get to enjoy these freedoms
because others have died for them so i'm
going to tell a few of those stories now
this is the the story of ben solomon he
was a surgeon at saipan during
world war ii his ipad was in the
marianas islands it was the site of
some pretty bloody battles according to
his medal
of honor actual description the
regiment's first and second battalions
because he was serving for the 105th
infantry regiment in the 27th infantry
division
the regiment's first and second
battalions were attacked by an
overwhelming force estimated between 3
000 and 5
000 japanese soldiers it was one of the
biggest attacks during the entire
pacific theater in world war ii the
enemy penetrated the battalion's
combined perimeter
and inflicted tremendous casualties in
the very first minutes of the attack
approximately 30 wounded soldiers walked
our crawls were carried
into captain salomon's aid station and
the small
tent was soon filled with wounded as the
perimeter began to be overrun
captain salomon was trying to work on
the wounded there were too many wounded
and then he saw a japanese soldier
bayonetting one of the wounded soldiers
lying near the tent and this is how
immediate the battle was
from a squatting position captain
salomon quickly killed the enemy soldier
as he turned his attention back to the
wounded two more japanese soldiers
appeared
in the front entrance of the tent as
these enemy soldiers were killed four
more crawled under the tent walls
captain solomon then kicked a knife out
of the hand of one shot another and
bayonetted a third
he butted the fourth enemy soldier in
the stomach and wounded comrade then
shot and killed the enemy soldier
captain solomon then ordered the wounded
to make their way as best they could
back to the regimental aid station
he attempted to hold off the enemy
essentially single-handedly
he grabbed a rifle from one of the
wounded he rushed out of the tent after
four men were killed while manning a
machine gun he then took control of the
machine gun when his body was later
found there were 98 dead enemy soldiers
piled
in front of his position an unbelievable
heroism this is the story of william
hawkins william hawkins
was decorated for valorous and gallant
conduct above and beyond the call of
duty
he was the commanding officer of a scout
sniper platoon attached to the second
marines in
action against japanese held tarawa in
the gilbert islands again this is
another
hugely bloody battle people tend to
underestimate the bloodiness of the
pacific war because so much media
attention is placed on the atlantic war
for a variety of
i think politically correct reasons the
pacific war was unbelievably bloody
the conduct of the japanese military was
incredibly vicious
in fact in terms of how the military
engaged with with american pows
significantly more vicious than the
pacific men in the atlantic
the first to disembark from a jeep
lighter first lieutenant hawkins
unhesitatingly moved forward under heavy
enemy fire
at the end of a pier neutralizing
emplacements and coverage of troops
assaulting the main breach positions
he led his men on to join the forces
fighting desperately to get a beachhead
and repeatedly risked his life
throughout the day and night to direct
elite attacks
attacks on pill boxes and installations
with grenades and demolition
first lieutenant hawkins returned to the
dangerous mission of clearing the
limited beachhead of japanese resistance
the following day
he personally initiated an assault on a
hostile fortified
by five enemy machine guns and crawling
forward in the face of withering fire
boldly
fired point blank into the loopholes and
completed the destruction with grenades
he was wounded in the chest in a serious
fashion and he steadfastly continued to
fight destroying three more pillboxes
before he was caught
in a burst of japanese shell fire and
mortally wounded and of course
there's a lot of focus in the united
states on world war ii
but the reality is that we've had so
many americans fall
in wars that are far less glorified by
the media the korean war the reason that
south korea exists today the korean war
the story brian womack a medic who
continued to help fellow soldiers even
after losing his arm in battle
private first class womack distinguished
himself he was the only medical aid man
attached to a night combat patrol when
sudden contact with the numerically
superior enemy produced numerous
casualties
according to his medal of honor
description
private first class womack went
immediately to their aid although this
necessitated exposing himself to a
devastating hail of enemy fire
during which he was seriously wounded
refusing medical aid himself
he continued to move among his comrades
administering aid while hitting one man
he was again struck by enemy motor fire
this time
he lost his right arm in the mortar fire
he still refused aid knowing that he
would probably die
he insisted all efforts be made for the
benefit of others who were wounded he
was unable to perform the task himself
but remained on scene and directed
others in first aid techniques
the last man's withdraw he walked until
he collapsed from loss of blood he died
a few minutes later while being carried
by his comrades vietnam
the media again tends to treat the
vietnam war as a sort of blot on
american history the reality is the men
who served in vietnam
were every bit as brave and heroic in
defending american freedoms yes and in
defending
the lives of the vietnamese as men who
served in korea or served in world war
ii or served in world war one
the fact that the media have tried to
treat america's loss
in vietnam as some sort of
boon to the world is full-scale insanity
the fact that hundreds of thousands of
people floated themselves off the coast
of vietnam in boats to escape the
clutches of ho chi minh the fact that
pol pot in the aftermath of america's
abandonment of vietnam
proceeded to murder a million cambodians
just demonstrates that where america
fades
evil tends to win steven bennett was the
pilot of a light aircraft flying an
artillery adjustment mission along a
heavily defended segment of root
structure
a large concentration of enemy troops
was massing for an attack on a friendly
unit
captain bennett requested tactical air
support but was advised that none was
available
he also requested artillery support but
this was denied as well because of the
proximity of friendly troops to the
target
captain bennett was still determined to
aid the endangered unit and elected to
strafe the hostile positions
after four passes the enemy force began
to retreat he continued the attack as he
completed his fifth strafing pass
his aircraft was struck by a
surface-to-air missile it damaged the
left engine and the left
main landing gear captain bennett did
realize that recovery at a friendly
airfield was impossible he instructed
his observer to prepare for an ejection
but he was informed by the observer that
his parachute had already been shredded
by the impacting missile captain bennett
did have a good parachute he could have
ejected
but he knew that if he did eject the
observer would die
captain bennett instead elected to ditch
the aircraft into the gulf of tonkin
even though he realized that a pilot of
this type of aircraft had never survived
the ditching
when the plane hit the water the
aircraft cartwheeled and damaged the
front cockpit
it was impossible for captain bennett to
escape the observer
did escape and was rescued humber roque
versace
he was granted the medal of honor for
his activity as a pow
during the vietnam war again people tend
to discount the treatment of american
pows in times of war at the hands of
vicious enemies
while accompanying a civilian irregular
defense group patrol engaged in combat
operations
captain versace and the citg assault
force were caught in an ambush from
intense mortar automatic weapons and
small arms fire from elements of a
reinforced enemy main force battalion
as the battle raged captain versace
fought valiantly and encouraged
his patrol to return fire against
overwhelming enemy forces he provided
covering fire from an exposed position
to enable friendly forces to withdraw
from the killing zone when it was
apparent their position would be overrun
he was severely wounded in the knee and
back from automatic weapons fire and
shrapnel
he resisted capture with the last full
measure of strength and ammunition who
was taken prisoner
by the vietcong he assumed command of
his fellow american prisoners despite
being kept in irons in an isolation box
raised their morale by singing messages
to popular songs of the day
leaving inspired messages at the latrine
within three weeks of captivity despite
the severity of his untreated wounds he
attempted the first of four escape
attempts by dragging himself on hands
and knees
out of the camp through swamp and
forbidding vegetation to freedom
crawling at a very slow pace because of
his weekend condition the guards
discovered him outside the camp
recaptured him
captain versace scorned their exhaustive
interrogation and indoctrination efforts
and inspired his fellow prisoners to
resist to the best of their ability
when he used his vietnamese language
skills to protest proper treatment of
the american prisoners by the guards he
was put into leg irons and gagged
to keep his protestations out of earshot
of the other american prisoners
the last time that his fellow prisoners
heard from him captain versace was
seeing god bless america at the top of
his voice
from his isolation box unable to break
his indomitable will
his faith in god and his trust in the
united states of america and his fellow
prisoners
he was executed by the viet cong
september 26 1965.
and these stories if these aren't enough
to remind you what has been sacrificed
for the freedoms we enjoy and really how
important it is that americans
appreciate their own history when people
say america has never
been good when people say that america
has never been great
these men were great and they fought in
defense of american values that are
indeed great they fought and died
and sacrificed their lives in defense of
something higher and that does mean
something
and every war has heroes like this every
war that america fights has heroes like
this because america is filled with
heroes like this
michael murphy in the war on terror his
team was pinned down in mountainous
terrain
he had to leave cover to make it a
higher ground so he could call for help
while leading a mission to locate
a high-level anti-coalition militia
leader lieutenant murphy demonstrated
extraordinary heroism
says his medal of honor citation in
afghanistan
on june 28 2005 operating in an
extremely rugged enemy controlled area
lieutenant murphy's team was discovered
by anti-coalition militia sympathizers
who revealed their position to taliban
fighters
as a result between 30 and 40 enemy
fighters besieged his four-member team
lieutenant murphy valiantly led his men
in engaging the large enemy force the
ensuing fierce firefight
resulted in numerous enemy casualties as
well as the wounding of all four members
of the team
ignoring his own wounds and
demonstrating exceptional composure
lieutenant murphy continued to lead and
encourages men
when the primary communicator fell
mortally wounded lieutenant murphy
repeatedly attempted to call for
assistance for his beleaguered teammates
realizing the impossibility of
communicating in the extreme terrain
in the face of almost certain death he
fought his way into open terrain to gain
a better position to transmit a call
this deprived him of cover exposing him
to direct enemy fire
finally achieving contact with his
headquarters lieutenant murphy
maintained his exposed position
well he provided his location and
requested immediate support for his team
he continued to engage the enemy until
he was mortally wounded gallantly giving
his life for his country and for the
cause
of freedom and if uh
if this isn't enough to to make all of
us feel a little bit more humble today
in the face of such bravery i honestly
don't know what would
as you celebrate memorial day and
commemorate memorial day
make it a meaningful one take some time
to remember people who are still
in the field risking their lives for
american freedoms
and remember that the people who stand
in the doorway guarding the united
states are people who
have made a choice that frankly is a
choice that i
myself have not been brave enough to
make their courage is
unquestionable their valor is
unquestionable and we thank them every
day for what they are doing we thank
those who have given their lives so that
we can enjoy days like this one